so to start with I'll explain there's
gonna be a lot of content throughout
this notebook but thankfully you guys
can get hold of it at the end so I were
looking at all the stuff I miss so this
is just a quickie table of contents what
we're going to go through as you can see
we're going to start with going through
a workflow using Wolfram Alpha pro
Mathematica and the online version they
will then go through teaching and
research applications of the Wolfram
language so to start with I wish to
introduce Wolfram Alpha which is
something I would hope you guys heard
before head off before which is actually
one of the powering pieces of technology
behind Siri if you happen to us Siri a
mathematical based question such as the
one shown on the screen now it will in
fact head over to all from alpha to find
out the information for you will from
our first our computational knowledge
engine which you can find as a website
version just by typing in on your
favorite browser Wolfram Alpha you'll be
able to ask a series of mathematical
questions let the time it would take for
you to get from New York to Oxford and
it will actually sit there and do all
the calculations for you including in
this case traffic here is a quick
visualization of that website as you can
see you can in fact be used for a
variety of mathematical applications I
used it for one during my dissertation
to assist me with complex mathematical
problems such as there are a variety of
differential and integration integral
equations not only does it provide you
with the solution but it also provides
you with a step through step by step
process as well the same system can we
actually be access directly through the
Wolfram language using either
Mathematica or our various cloud
development platforms just by using your
the equals sign on your keyboard so
click into an empty cell like so and
then just press equals and you'll see it
comes up with a lovely field which you
can put in your question and it will
answer you answer answer just the same
as it would on a on the web
browser-based version
there are a series of tools within the
Mathematica and the cloud versions that
you will find particularly useful my
favorite has got to be the suggestions
bar if you happen to be typing in a
question so in this case I'll just
evaluate the one on screen you'll see
that it should come up with a
suggestions bar of things that do next
unfortunately due to the presentation
mode that's not going to happen today
normally there'd be a lovely bar at the
bottom which would suggest a load of out
of things that you may wish to try next
such as in this case a visualization of
the equation in question when it comes
to the Wolfram language there are three
simple rules to Romola all functions
that we've put into Mathematica are in
fact capitalized such as the plot
functions shown below you can see that
we surround function arguments using
square brackets and then curly brackets
in fact dodo lists and ranges and other
data structures there is in fact a
series of other useful tools which I'm
not gonna go to into much detail such as
the input assistance which is very
similar to the autocorrect on your phone
so for example if I start typing in plot
as you can see it comes up with the last
series of suggestions of things I may be
attempting to do I can click on any of
these and it will give me a template
with which to fit out which is very
useful and always the correct format and
use for that function there's also a
series of palettes which as you'll see
on my screen by clicking on this menu
here they're intended as a series of
useful tools that allow you to do
programming and visual aids very easily
my favorite thing has got to be the
documentation center which has a list of
every single function we have in there
split up into various domains of what
things you may be wishing to try such as
image processing and stuff
and image processing sound analysis
graph theory etc and you'll tell you
everything from use of the function to
templates to guides and tutorials and
what do we expect these things to be
useful we have an online platform which
amusingly enough we've called
mathematical online the system itself is
pretty much exactly the same as
mathematically I'm using here but it's
available through a browser which as
we've worked as we've noticed is very
useful for tablets and phones and allows
you to develop on the move or if you
don't happen to have a PC then being
able to develop on the device that you
everybody seems to have which is a
mobile phone is quite a powerful tool as
it shows there's no record installation
required you just open it in your
browser by by typing in ww1 cloud.com
as I've attempted to point out their
language is exactly the same the palates
the auto-completion
and the suggestions well shown in the
bottom of this image is all exactly the
same including all the visualizations
there is no difference of at the fact
that it happens to be in a browser and
doesn't require install so now onto
teaching applications so we have a
series of functions which we bit which
such as manipulate which we believe are
really particularly useful tool when it
comes to presenting a variety of
concepts to others so in this case I can
quite happily plot a sine function using
a very simple piece of coding that's a
nice and interesting visualization but
rather static great thing about this
though is that I can then put this into
a very simple function known as I
manipulate very simply as so so in fact
we start as a one good otherwise you
won't see it very well
and then change that to return so just a
bit of live coding for your other and
what it results in is an interactive
manipulate which you can then use to
change to show the variation of
something live in front of people like
I'm doing now a nice and simple but
powerful tool this works with a large
variety of functions several of which I
can not necessarily go into but here
isn't just an expansion of a simple
bracket soup series of brackets the
great thing is I can put this then put
this into a me and if you're late and it
will go on and on and on as long as I've
put that in the parameter so as you can
see it's not necessarily just grass and
things like that
thing about visas these can go into as
complex or as simple as you like so as
you can see here you can affect the
frequency the amplitude shift in very in
a variety of different methods and can
even change the function so these can go
as really a simple as complicated as you
like based on what you're intending to
do there is a little fun thing here to
play around with when you're holding a
notebook and if you just place an image
within there you can sit there and play
around and blur the image in and out as
you so choose just drag and drop your
image from your favorite website again
this manipulate system can be used again
on the mathematical online platform
because it's exactly the same both on
desktop and online another useful
feature is our extensive library of
pre-built materials we have the Wolfram
demonstrations project which is a
ridiculously large series of
demonstrations that go through the large
variety of topics we have available in
our programming language processing ones
there's some system modeling etc etc so
another particularly reduce is after
you've produced all your interesting
materials whatever they may happen to be
you can then very easily share these in
a very in a incredibly simple manner so
I'm just gonna re importar logo directly
from our website
this was the little tool I showed you
that I showed you the code for earlier
I've just put the Wolfram logo in it so
I can sit there and blur that in and out
quite nice and easily the great thing is
using this very simple coding here I can
live in front of you now deploy that in
a CDF manner which in which it will turn
to me a URL which I can click on and if
you particularly were want to take a
screenshot of that and put that into
your browser you'd find that you're able
to access that right now and play around
with it appropriately because the
permissions are set to public that took
all of two seconds
these things can go into a more
complicated manner this here is the code
requires to embed that same little
application into a website or a course
management system for example this
system can actually be used to produce
coding for a variety of different
programming languages depending on what
you're intending to the usual stuff for
well I've mentioned the Wolfram Alpha
integration previously what this
actually means is we have a large
amounts of real world data which you can
actually pull into your home language
coding and use that within your
applications so in this case I can look
up the melting points of caffeine a very
simple piece of information which one
fortunately doesn't seem to be working
perfectly at the moment but as you can
see it's produced me the mounting points
are curvy that's actually a symbolic
objects which I can then use to progress
and use within my calculations nice and
easily if I'm looking for something a
bit more complicated I can actually look
up the gift the structure the chemical
structure of caffeine and as you can see
it's done that for me I can do a series
of image analysis or structural analysis
on this because again it's a symbolic
object it can be used within my
computations really simply and easily
one of the things that I'm keen to
express here is the fact that we have a
large amount of data on a large variety
of subjects so this is just the amount
of data we have purely on just chemicals
we have over 44,000 records so you've
done that live in front of you just to
make sure that you were aware of it here
is a series of ten items that you can
find within that chemical data just as
an example and each of those has a long
list of properties half of which well
over half of which I do not understand
but if you're a chemist I can imagine
they're incredibly useful for you as I
said is on a variety of topics we are
not we're not limited to just chemistry
just as an amusement piece a bit of a
muse
Pease we have the molecular plot of
caffeine as well just to show that we do
do 3d and three-dimensional objects of
which you can sit and play around with
annotate so they're not knighted they're
not simple and Static there's just a
quick link there to use of the wolf over
the Wolfram language in a chemistry
classroom and it's a live application
and just in case you are very interested
particularly in that one so again a
simple code to pull out this large part
of bits of information from this large
data repository in this case we're
pulling out the literacy literacy
fraction of Zimbabwe just one of the
tiny pieces of information we have on
such a country but the great thing is
you can actually plot this across this
same piece of information across the
entirety of Africa and then display it
in an interesting bar chart like so so
nice and easy
nothing particularly complicated in fact
that coding is incredibly easy to read
as well if you're then once or then
continue to make this interactive again
nice and simple here you can see this
turned into an application so same thing
country data of a continent illiteracy
fraction and then a series of continents
you wish to choose from so let's change
over to Europe so again you can see the
literacy rate across that continent
we're not limited to just simple
geographical data we can also use
weather data so here we currently have
the temperature in the State College
this can then be converted into
Fahrenheit because I'm aware that the
Americans struggle with a centigrade
system but the great thing is you can
then again very easily plot this plot
such data across a time line so here is
just a simple dateless plot of the
weather data in this case particularly
pressure on the fifth month in 2016 this
can then be overlaid with a series of
other data so you can do direct
comparisons quite nice and easily
again the coding is fairly simple so
much so that I'm happy to show you it
geographical date
was also included so here we have a map
of champagne which is the location of
our office in America but this this
geographical data can be used along with
actual population data and you can then
graph the population data directly over
the map so in this case we are showing
you the population by region in China
nice and simple key thing event a key to
express now is the fact that I've gone
through and shown you how we can use our
data that we've put into the Wolfram
Alpha knowledge database you can quite
easily work with your own data wherever
it happens to be the most common tends
to be Excel spreadsheets or a series of
databases will happily support pretty
much all of it the great thing is that
it doesn't matter where your data is we
support a ridiculously large amount of
formats here is a series of examples
based on some expected ideas here is the
actual list of all the format's than
fact that's out of dates bear with you
here is a list of all the data formats
we actually support currently they have
a variety of uses this list actually
extends annually or whenever we do a new
or from a language update so we believe
that you should be able to find a format
which is useful to you and is quite
helpful what you'll find is there is
actually underneath to do nine different
formats that we currently support as I
said this increases with every new
release we also have the Wolfram data
drop which is our data storage for the
Wolfram cloud also accessible via dated
via desktop so here I'm creating my own
little repository for a series of data I
can then retrieve that data directly
from the actual repository itself and
then plot it again in threes very simple
lines of coding nothing too complicated
this can also be done with images so
here's an image of a lovely dog which I
also stored in that de turban the great
thing is that I don't even have
swap between data bins for the different
types of data I can store images and
numbers all within the same location
just be careful how it's used
I can then switch to doing some image
processing so I can find the outline
I've said dog quite nice and easily but
great thing is I can then turn stuff
into something more interesting for you
guys to see such as a manipulate where
it can change the variable of how many
edges I wish to detect this stuff can
them you can then be cloud deployed as a
form page quite quite quite nice and
quickly so this is actually the
deployment of a form page which takes an
XLS document and will automatically plot
it for you so it doesn't matter what the
data is in there the system will
automatically interpret it interpret
that document an attempt to process it
in a very interesting and sensible
manner information can also be imported
directly from a URL in this case this
happens to be a URL link into a
particular file it could be an a URL
linking to an API or an entire website
and then you can pull in you can then go
down into a granular level level and
pick out the information you actually
want from your report so all of this has
been leading up to the idea of running a
class with the mathematical online
system so you'd create your own a
turbine this is setting up a form page
to be honest with you this is the actual
construction of the form page that's
letting it know how to store the
information and as you can see some of
you some appearance rules to make sure
it displays in a nice manner then cloud
deploy that form so that you guys can
access it publicly normally if I had
more time I'd go through and allow you
guys to actually fill out that form I
don't unfortunately don't have that time
today the great thing is because as you
can see that URL is quite long and
doesn't necessarily make much sense we
have a function known as URL shorten
where you put in the URL that we've
created put in what you wish it to be
called and as you can see here we end up
with a shortened version which is a much
much easier to type in at speed
normally I'd then go through and show
the information that people have already
submitted but again not enough time here
so here is a quick demonstration of how
comprehensive the language is this is
actually a graph of the number of
algorithms and functions we put into the
Wolfram language populated by the flags
for the various different Mathematica
releases as you can see it's written it
quite a ridiculous rate over the past
few years and will continue to do so for
as far as well for as long as I'm aware
of all the list is led by our symbolic
computation which is normally which is
evidently shown by our step by step
solutions in Wolfram Alpha Pro but
otherwise as you can see the step way
the symbolic nature can be used quite
nicely to do some very interesting and
complicated mathematics so here is just
a simple integral of a equation with
reference to X as you can see it's in a
format which you guys can quite happily
understand the full form of this is also
available this is a shorthand version
you can actually type this in quite nice
and easy using the palettes which is how
I did it myself with which it gives you
the typesetting to actually do this in a
nice and interesting manner again you
can do the same with a variety of
different equations etc you can then use
a series of multi-step problems and
wouldn't display those as just as easily
in mini players with shown previous our
symbolic computations makes working with
numerix incredibly easy I don't know
about you guys but a plus B is quite
nice is always all well and good but I
would prefer to actually put a objects
or a numeric in there and Mathematica
does pretty much exactly the same thing
it will store a value a variable or
value in that variable whether you call
it X Y Z or just because and then it
will happily reinsert that as
appropriate a more interesting effect of
this of this symbolic calculation system
is the unit unit computations so here
I've added a series of three different
units together and as you can see it's
actually returned to me a sensible
system this can quite easily be done
using the equals shown earlier so click
into your cell push equals type in your
units so 2.3 pounds so that'd have to be
British pounds in this case he says
British pounds I missed the years well
the great thing is I could actually
evaluate this and it will deter me a
entity which would represent 2.3 British
pounds which actually comes to be two
pounds 33 pence the great thing is this
couldn't computation such as these
condemned we've done on it afterwards
here is just a series of examples of
doing exactly the same thing I have a
quantity of 3 feet adding two inches
transmitted with a result of 38 inches
can then find out whether three feet is
less than one meter and it turns out it
is and then you can do things such as
converting feet into meters so there's
your answer to prove that it is in fact
less than one meter you can also
simplify units so for example joules per
second which turns out to be what's
normally Mathematica will do this
automatically for you I'm just doing
this by manually to show you exactly
what it would be doing so if you did
have a calculation that would result in
something of joules divided by set of
seconds then it would automatically
turns that into what's for you this can
then be used on other things such as
axes so as you can see here I'm able to
put a unit stare into a series of axis
into an axis on the graph nice and easy
so one of the most powerful features of
everything I've shown you so far is the
ability to pretty much compute and
visualize anything I am not joking what
I mean every anything we can do to dated
2d visualizations and a quite a large
variety of those here is a series of
eight examples we can do 3d
visualizations this is going to take a
second to load all of these can actually
be I could sit here and manipulating
rotate them and zoom in and out and have
a look at the features in more detail
fortunately I'm not gonna be able to do
this on a webinar but then we have more
specialized data visualizations
including ones including some
specialized plots for things such as
engineering social networks and
statistics one of the things that is
very important with the Wolfram language
is the consistency of its syntax it
doesn't matter whether you're plotting
any data plotting a curve or doing the
integral of that's very same equation
the syntax is pretty much exactly the
same
I literally copied and pasted this and
change the word plot to integrate you
can then again change this into a
three-dimensional thing again
then by changing very little you can
then turn that into a mere plate where
you can choose 2d plot or density
nothing complicated
the intuitive syntax of the entire
language makes things such as ordinary
differential equation homework really
easy to learn
so our syntax can actually be displayed
in exactly the same way on this piece of
pattern this example piece of homework
here so not only can you go from a piece
of homework which your lecturer is
giving you direct or Wolfram language
you can actually get out your answers
very easily and type it in exactly as
you see it on the piece of paper other
pieces of software such as MATLAB
unfortunately do not have this
functionality so as you can see here
here's the atte me during that exact
piece of homework in MATLAB and it does
take a lot longer than I intended it to
one
to highlight is the ability to do all of
this on a browser so getting hold of
mathematical license is preferable it
means that you can use the resources you
have available on your local machine but
if that's not necessary available to you
then we have here a series of abilities
for browser for browser-based
applications which allows you as I said
before to use either tablets or mobile
phones we even have a Wolfram cloud app
itself which is optimized specifically
for iOS and Android
again Mathematica online is free to all
users so just a quick summary of the
teaching applications we've gone through
the tools which we fight which we have
to make programming easier showing that
you can make concepts easy for students
show how you can then create everything
dynamically with by easily swapping
between various between using the same
syntax and just replacing certain
components showing how you can integrate
your real word data with your
computations to actually make things
applicable to a variety of subject areas
and then just highlighting the fact that
you don't necessarily need a desktop
version to actually access all this so
now to specifically highlight things for
research here is a series of examples of
what Mathematica is actually currently
useful I'm not going to go into these in
any detail but as you can see though
there is a large variety of actual real
world application use for Mathematica at
the moment so to make research easier
there is a series of features one of our
the one of the things that we're most
proud of is our parallel computation and
GPU support so I don't know about you
guys being able to do having to do
things sequentially means that it can
take quite a long time in this case
parallelizing such a thing as the as a
sum can actually speed things up into
quite quite quickly in this case they're
not gonna be able to do this for you now
because it does actually take some time
and I don't have that enough time today
but you can run these on your local
computer try doing them normally first
and timing them
then adding the parallel ice and you'll
find that the speed is actually quicker
there is a blog on our website which you
can find which shows how you can
quantify the speed with which these
things are done another thing I
mentioned is GPU support if you happen
to be as lucky as me and have a Nvidia
graphics card within your PC you'll find
that you can use that to in prayer
increase the speed of some of your
computations so specifically neural
networks linear linear algebra some
financial computations quite a lot of
image processing because I'm using a
graphics card can be used for image
processing a lot faster who would have
guessed and Fourier transforms there are
other function there are a lot of
functions which are automatic in their
use of the order of your GPU if you have
one here there is a series of three
examples here which you'll be able to
look through in your own time which
highlight its use programming
Mathematica come in done in a variety of
different programming styles it's
incredibly multi-paradigm and has a
large and broad range of constructs if
you particularly are focused on the
procedural side of programming then
you'll be using something along the
lines of this these two lines of coding
here but if you particularly believe in
using entirely functional coding then
you can be then you can go along with
this line of coding here the idea is
that we're attending to make
mathematical language or the Wolfram Pro
dilemma damage as flexible as possible
here is just a few examples of the
functional programming side of things so
just defining a function that where
we'll take a variable a value of x and
square it by inputting the value 10 we
get 100 the value 3.1415 but this can
also be then applied to a serie a list
of numbers or if you particularly wish
to it can be prepared done to an object
in this case Mathematica the Wolfram
language isn't able to actually
determine what it is but it still gives
it tells you it's squared it you can
then define functions that behave
differently depending on what the
argument is that's actually provided so
in this case if the number provided
an integer I wanted to perform this
function if the number happens to be
real then I would liked the number of pi
to 50 decimal places if the item happens
to be a string return a red dot so just
to check it first an integer hey presto
the sign 1 over 9 then a real number you
get PI to 50 decimal places and then if
I give it the word test I go returned a
red dot I don't about you guys but this
can actually be incredibly powerful the
Wolfram language syntax allows us to
create incredibly powerful programs with
very little syntax here is a tweetable
program which in fact returns in a list
of possible Scrabble words from a list
of tiles so here I've given it the
letters a o ru Y and M and it should
return
a list of possible uses of those letters
within the game of Scrabble quite a
powerful thing as you can see very
little actual coding but it means that
you can create some very powerful small
programs again you can also build
dynamic graphics with very little syntax
so here is a lovely little animation
that is created in what actually should
be one line of coding but within the
character range of a Twitter the old
character range of a tweet again you can
then do things such as shortest paths
examples and there's a there's several
more examples further down which you can
then go into yourselves including the
including changing things into parallel
I can't go through all of these today
because I am limited on my time
unfortunately so another thing within
research is the ability to do things at
speed so we have code compiled Asian
which allows things to be again as I
said faster the major bone and one of
the major thing as I keep saying a major
benefit is making everything faster in
this case we're going to compile for a
different variety of up select optional
executions optimal there we go got the
right word so as I mentioned earlier you
can do timing of these functions so here
you can see that the timing for the do
different compilation methods is quite
significantly different you can also do
compiling specifically for
parallelization which I am hopefully
able to show you now here we go
give it a second you can also use you
could also automatically generate code
so for example I'm going to use change
the equation x squared plus sine of x
squared and I'm come back I'm going to
compile it into a series of C code
so I've just stored the compact a
compiled version of the equation load
the code generator package and I've just
realized I've missed out something so
I'm going to have to come back to that
another time what you should be able to
do is compile this into C code and then
you'll be able to publish that C code
and whatever method you chose choose and
use it on your Windows computer in a
much faster manner
one of the things we key to Express is
that we're not you're not necessarily
limited in where you store your data one
of the things that I mentioned here is
the integration with our we also have
integration with other database and a
variety of other systems such as
Java based systems SQL etc we also have
an IDE available as well as warfarin web
bench which can be plugged into the
other development environments such as
Eclipse Mathematica cell
as a series of function built-in
functionality that applies to a large
range of areas so here is just an
example of six so unlike traditional
systems where you would have to go
through and very programming programs or
what you happen to be doing at the time
the idea in Mathematica is you can just
open this one program and you have all
those tools available in one location no
more worrying about file file formats
weren't transferring between programs or
changing to a new program just to do
presentation as you can see today I'm in
fact using one wolfram mathematica to do
this presentation here is a series of
examples of a variety of uses of the
Wolfram language and over in a series of
different domains again I don't
necessarily have the time to do today
but as I mentioned you'll be given this
presentation so that you can go through
it in your own time
just a quick nod to Wolfram system
modeler if you happen to be into
modeling and simulating systems here is
a series of example locations where that
may be useful then we have system model
itself which actually has an access to a
large variety of Metallica standard
libraries with which you can drag and
drop components to construct systems or
you can create your own this has a
variety of linking capabilities
indirectly into Mathematica which allows
you to do analysis of the systems with
it from within Mathematica but just to
highlight system modeler isn't a
different is a separate piece of
software as currently here is just a for
example of a few case studies with which
Wolfram system water is used everything
ranging from the Ford f-350 truck to an
analysis of a human system so you're not
necessarily limited to mechanical
electrical engineering within system
modeler there is also the ability to do
biological systems as well however they
are a bit more complicated than I would
like to admit and here is a serie a it
all of this use within mechanics again
we have demonstrations where here are
two links with which you can click on
which will show you a few demonstration
of using mathematic its control to
control the simulation of either
electric kettle or a excavator here are
a series of academic initiatives which
you may guys may or may not be
interested in which will allow you to
get hold of Mathematica Wolfram Alpha
Pro and mathematic are online quite nice
and easily again all the details are at
the end of this presentation so feel
free to look through this in your own
time and yeah any questions